all right turning now to the hit series
genie in Georgia which has been
dominating the Netflix top 10 list and
leaving fans on the edge of their seats
the show Stars Brianne Howey as Georgia
Miller a young and free-spirited mom
with kids Jenny and Austin they move
looking for a fresh start but Georgia's
secret pass continues to follow them
well season two streaming now Shows
Georgia navigating Life as a busy mom
and her complicated relationship with
her kids take a look
oh Mom I need a note for school
what should we say alligator back long
FBI consultation emergency
yeah
I said you had the flu
this is good parenting accio blueberries
Jenny you need one
accio syrup you don't want to know no
you're just gonna stroll in after a week
with an air of Mystique and zero
explanation black share
just let me write you I know I'm fine
bye Austin bye Paul
bye sweetheart you have a good day too
[Music]
Brianne Howie joins us now good morning
to you thank you for coming in I have to
say this is so fresh and different and
complex did you expect it to be as
popular as it is and what do you think
it is that is resonating with so many
people I think you always hope but
certainly while you're shooting it you
have no idea how or if it's going to
resonate
um we hoped it would resonate with the Y
A audience and I think discovering that
it's resonating with even more
demographics outside of that has been uh
pretty mind-blowing and I think the show
it's a really good conversation starter
for a lot of complicated subjects like
mental health and race and love and
self-harm and I think it's brought about
in a really authentic way that is gives
people permission to find their
catharsis in it and identify with it
yeah there's a lot of good shows out
there that you may not audition for want
to be in because you don't think you're
right for it but you crush this roll why
did you want to take it on I actually at
First wasn't sure I was like they're not
going to believe me as a mom like what
um but it was the scene where Georgia
takes her son to school and gives the
other kid a bloody nose who believed him
that really really hooked me and I've
never read a role like Georgia she's so
Dynamic there's a lot of gray area and I
think that brings to life our Humanity
you grew up with a single mom I did
um what about your experience growing up
with a single mom help you with this
role I think
there's a lot of boundaries that get
crossed when you are so close in age
with a parental figure yeah and I think
it made a lot of the scenes in Jenny and
Georgia that could have come across
really jarring more normalized for me
I've had these conversations were you
close in age with your mom my mom had me
at 21. okay yes so she yeah she had me
young not quite as young as Georgia but
right at the end of the first episode of
the first season
um I think it was a moment where Antonio
Gentry who plays Jenny said I think this
is the moment where I'm starting to
understand my mom right did you feel
that way after playing this role like
did you feel like you had a better sense
or connection with what your mother went
through of course you can't not I mean I
don't have a family yet so this is the
closest thing to it I have a lot of
younger siblings that I would do
anything for
um but of course I already had so much
respect for my mom but now after playing
Georgia I just bow down to all single
parents it is you're trying to hustle
you're trying to navigate you got to be
the good cop and the bad up and that's
not easy what does your mom think about
your role I think she's very happy about
it I think she hasn't told you yes no
yes
that's great
any more Bombshells we
can too as the past of Georgia catches
up with the present so many Bombshells I
don't want to spoil anything but um
absolutely what's fun about season two
is there's a lot of fun new character
pairings that bring out a whole new side
to every character so you see a flip
side of everyone that's kind of
surprising you you mentioned mental
health and there's also this idea of
therapy right and it has been Taboo in
the past I don't think not so much
anymore right what would be your advice
for individuals that might be seeking
therapy or dealing with mental health
I think one of my favorite Parts about
season two is that Ginny asks for help
and I think one of the most important
messages from season two is that it's
okay to not be okay yeah and that's not
something that we've normalized as a
society and I think it takes a lot of
courage to live in your vulnerability so
I think if people can take that away
from the show
it's okay to ask for help exactly and
it's okay to not be okay
um I don't know I don't know yet but
it's feeling positive okay we'll go with
that yeah yeah well thank you for all
your positive energy this morning and
thank you for coming in Brienne Howie
you can make sure you check her out
along with all of the other great actor
acting in that and Jenny in Georgia
which is streaming right now on Netflix